ein pinkl skandal unter promis
aufgedeckt durch diese
überwachungskamera tatort bodenwerder
ein dörfchen in niedersachsen dort
herrscht kein toiletten notstand nein
das was sie hier sehen das ist eine
pinkel attacke vorsätzlich und der der
pinkelt der hat dsds gewonnen
deutschland sucht den superstar jan
martin bock das ist sein name dsds
sieger vom letzten jahr und das ist der
pinkler und er pinkelt nicht irgend
jemanden ans auto sondern einem den er
sehr sehr gut kennt seinem einzigen show
konkurrenten bei dsds nämlich dass es
dieser mann hier kevin jene wein im
letzten jahr auf platz drei bei dsds
deutschland sucht den superstar er ist
dass pinkl opfer und das sagt er selbst
dazu in diesem video
der gewinner von 2021 dsds ihre marken
blog eigentlich was ich dachte ein
freund von mir
erst mal die komplette kader zu und das
nicht nur einmal nämlich jetzt habe ich
schon später kam er wieder und mit
seinem kumpel pinkelt wieder ging mein
auto und der kumpel hat seinen hintern
seinen blanken hintern aber im auto und
danach lassen sie sich ab und ich war
unfassbar gestand ich hätte niemals
damit gerechnet dass er das war niemals
ich hätte meine hand dafür ins feuer
gelegt ich hätte ihm sowas nicht
zugetraut
ja das ist also pinkl opfer kevin
jenewein drittplatzierter bei
deutschland sucht den superstar ihm also
hat der dsds sieger ans auto gepinkelt
einmal und dann 45 minuten später gleich
nochmal und alles festgehalten eben von
der überwachungskamera hier wie sie
nochmal sehen kss der schmutzige
höhepunkt eines schon lange anhaltenden
streits der beiden die beiden hassen
sich inzwischen niemand gönnt dem
anderen dessen erfolg und jetzt diese
unangenehme pinkel attacke jetzt bitte
einmal in die wahrscheinlich sagen
bedingt und pinkel skandal das erinnert
mich sofort ja jetzt an deutschland
sucht den superstar aber an den aller
berühmtesten aller pinkl skandale den
könig der pinkler beziehungsweise prinz
ernst august von hannover
das war im jahr 2000 als bei der expo in
hannover an den türkischen pavillon und
pinkelte seitdem war er für deutschland
für die ganze welt der pinke prinz das
also der berühmteste pinkl skandal jetzt
möglicherweise abgelöst durch diesen
pinkl skandal unter den dsds stars gibt
es einen neuen platz 1 auf meinen möchte
oder nicht sei mal dahin gestellt
[Musik]